[Musik]
[Applaus]
liebe vor mit 12 fragen wie gut ist
weitere waters und wie lange dauert es
noch bis ferrari den rückstand auf
mercedes aufgeholt hat die zwei fragen
beschäftigen die formel 1 in barcelona
vor dem großen preis von spanien an
diesem sonntag weltreporter ist auf die
pole position gefahren 0,6 sekunden
schneller als sein teamkollege lewis
hamilton
das ist ein ziemlich beeindruckende
vorsprung
ich wüsste nicht wann hamilton das
letzte mal so viel rückstand auf seinen
teamkollegen hatte
man darf gespannt sein wie der start
verläuft hier beim rennen am sonntag und
wie aggressiv förmigen versuchen wir an
bord das vorbei zu kommen denn wer als
erstes durch die erste kurve kommt hat
äußerst gute chancen dieses rennen zu
gewinnen
die grossen geschlagenen wieder mal
ferrari
dabei ist die scuderia hier mit einem
überarbeiteten motor angetreten man
hatte sich viel versprochen
am ende reichte es für sebastian vettel
immerhin für den dritten platz schneller
als sein teamkollege erklärt der fünfter
wurde
dazwischen noch max fest tappen im red
bull aber trotzdem der abstand gewaltig
auf vortag fehlten vettel 0,8 sekunden
lag er war über eine sekunde zurück und
vettel sagte am ende das auto ist gut
aber nicht schnell genug
oder ist fühlt sich gut an ist aber
nicht schnell genug
und der vorsprung von mercedes scheint
sogar größer geworden zu sein
nach allem was die trainings bisher
gezeigt haben muss man damit rechnen
dass das im rennen nicht anders sein
wird
insofern könnte es tatsächlich auch in
barcelona dazu beitragen dass man die
spannung in dieser saison tatsächlich
nur aus dem teaminternen duell bei
mercedes ziehen kann kann alter
reporters tatsächlich zum großen rivalen
von hamilton werden
wir werden es sehen hier in barcelona
beim großen preis von spanien
[Musik]
[Applaus]